bundesminister zusammen und der west
city bekommen sich das konkret
vorstellen
wir haben auf der einen seite ein
konkretes angebot gemacht nämlich ab dem
zeitpunkt ab dem klar war dass die osze
sozusagen die organisation für diese
beobachtermission übernimmt haben wir
unser know how zur verfügung gestellt um
professionell die einsatzvorbereitung
dieser beobachter in der mission
unterstützen zu können
ich freue mich dass die osc dieses
angebot auch angenommen hat wir haben im
heurigen jahr vier missionen bzw
operationen in der ausbildung vorgesehen
und auch für das kommende jahr noch
angeboten weil ganz offen gesagt
diese beobachtermission ist für die
internationale staatengemeinschaft ein
wichtiges instrument auch im bereich der
konkreten lage bildentwicklung darüber
hinaus gibt sie auch der politik
wichtige grundlagen informationen